pages
[Music]
do
so
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i didn't get my whistle i
tried hello good evening
welcome to the table my name is kelly
and my skirt has pockets
so you can get on amazon but i just want
i knew everyone was wondering so i
thought i'd share that bit of
information i have a few announcements
next sunday is the first sunday of the
month
and usually we all go after church and
kick it at hat creek and have dinner
together but that's the day before the
4th of july so we'll be hanging here if
you would like and there's going to be a
firework show here at pleasant valley
their church so if you'd like to join
after church next sunday please do
and
is there food free hot dogs
fun music
and of course fireworks
um and then save the date later in the
summer there is our summer rama that is
kindergarten through sixth grade it'll
be held here and it's going to be super
duper fun brett has already sent out an
email about it but if you need more
information just reach out and register
we would love to have your kids there if
you want to volunteer i'm sure there's
room for that too um
and then
uh i'm going to transition this over to
brett who has some sweet words to share
with your beautiful hearts
i'm going to keep this all yours
all right
thanks for being here everyone um i know
some of you are finding your seat and
that's that's great so um i wanted to
take a minute to speak to everything
that happened this week so i um and by
the way i'm speaking kind of on um not
kind of i am speaking on behalf of the
elder team um
so i sent out my prayer checks thursday
and then everything happened with roe v
wade and supreme court decision and such
um i think was it early friday or late
thursday or um so by friday a number of
you had started to respond to my prayer
text and
um
and you know we're processing a lot
of things around that
and um
i know
just from from being in touch with you
and um and even just processing myself i
know there's this this topic it just
stirs up a whole host of feelings um all
across the political spectrum honestly
and to be clear here at the table we
have folks
all across the political spectrum
um
and
so i think that's that's made this um
just i think in ways one that sort of um
a challenging one i'll just be
vulnerable for me as a pastor it's been
very hard to know quite how to
respond
which is why i've been processing and
praying and um and seeking the elder
team's kind of wisdom um on this and um
what we
as we process what we just wanted to
name
is that um
this
topic it brings up
a lot of shame
and
oftentimes kind of silence from churches
and a sense of um isolation
um not only for those who have like had
abortions but even those um who have
just suffered some sort of like sexual
trauma
and
here in our community we just um we
don't want to be a church
that um
adds to people's pain
or their shame or their isolation
their sense of not being seen or
understood or loved
and so
um
i mean quite the opposite honestly and i
hope that's come through week after week
after week you know as we've been here
we we want to be a community where
people
can gather and feel loved and seen and
valued
right where they're at now adding to the
complexity of this
is that we are of course um a you know
lgbtqi plus like affirming community and
i know for for many of us the there's a
kind of second fear which is you know
following on the heels of this decision
what might be next
and there's a lot of concern that um
there might be an overturning of um gay
marriage
and that of course again just stirs up
more
emotion um more fear
and
um
so tonight we wanted to um just
acknowledge that fear
you know name it
and um
and name that that we are standing
with you
with our lgbtqi plus um friends and
folks who call the table home like we're
with you we love you we're for you
um our prayers
are with you
and um
and we want to do all we can to
to not only be there for you but to even
advocate for
um
change and
a better world
so i also wanted to um
to remember
like let's let's not put
our hope
in
human
o2 human institutions
um politicians
um governments
but christ and his kingdom
and let's
let's use this as an opportunity to
respond in a way where we are galvanized
to love well
even better than we have been doing
and um and let's do our best to continue
living out on earth as it is in heaven
let's seek justice
and together let's trust god to
bring us through
so um so that's that's our heart
and um i want to pray
as we um
start to enter into our time of worship
so let me lift you all up god we
we stand before you
feeling all sorts of feelings god
and
i pray over those who
feel most of all just afraid god there
can be just such
fear
um
and a sense of being unloved
not valued
and so i i pray god that by your spirit
we would be
slowly transformed into fearlessness
that we would
be transformed into people that feel
known and loved and seen and valued
that you would speak to the depths of
our being
and
bring
deep deep healing
god so work among us
draw us towards one another and not
apart
god draws to
yourself
we love you
it's the powerful life-changing name of
jesus that i pray
amen
[Music]
you guys want to go ahead and stand with
us mel's going to get us started on this
first song
[Music]
day
that i can't explain
feels like
is the blood of christ i have been
redeemed
where the spirit of the lord is
indeed
amen
thank god almighty i
let it go
[Music]
we're free
we thank you jesus
[Music]
and where the spirit of the lord is
there is freedom and i am free
amen
where the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
and i am free amen
we're the spirit
where the spirit of the lord is there is
freedom
and i am free amen we're free
[Music]
there is freedom
and i am free amen
all right
thank you guys
kids y'all are released to go to your
classrooms
[Music]
we're gonna start this
next song called i lose my ability
[Music]
and i was telling mel and gary earlier
it's so easy sometimes like on the
musical side of things i don't know how
many of you guys play instruments but
sometimes it's easy to start like
executing the music and forget
to pay attention to what you might be
singing or playing
and like
invest your heart and your soul into it
are any of you guys musicians out there
i know some of you sing kelly is like a
rock star musician
but
but for real
i think we all relate like when we're
going through our life sometimes it's so
easy to get caught up in the motion of
things that you literally end what you
were just doing and it's like what did i
just do like
what what was it that i said in that
conversation you know what i mean i was
just kind of going through my agenda
so i just invite you guys i'm inviting
myself
to think about what i'm saying
and consider do i believe
what i'm saying
and if you do
get vulnerable a little bit and let some
of the walls come down and see what god
might be saying
to you as you say these words as you
hear these chords as we play these notes
together let's enter in as a community
and let our hearts be heard
let our lives be spilled out let jesus
into this moment with us and see what he
wants to do in it
i lose my ability
to be afraid when i
see the way you
love me
and all the fear that held my
feet to the floor
it don't hold me anymore
[Music]
when i
see your face
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
you got this way of
chasing away those
shadows
lord i fall
down again
i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
everything changes in the
radiance of your smile
[Music]
fall
lord i've fallen down again
i'm finding out just who
i am
[Music]
goodbye hopelessness
is
[Music]
hello mercy hello peace
everything
[Music]
shadows
everything changes in the
radiance to your smile
[Music]
[Applause]
fall
down again
i'm finding out just who i am
[Music]
lord i fall down again
i'm finding out just who
i
am let's say that one more time
lord i fall down again
i'm finding out
just who
i
am
and hello joy hello true
hello love i've long for you
i've waited for
[Music]
yes
just reminded of that scripture that
says in his weakness i mean in our
weakness he is strong
and i just feel like that's
where a lot of us
[Music]
need to embrace some of those weak
moments right now the ones where we're
feeling scared or afraid
where we're feeling insecure or
vulnerable
and allow him to be our strength
[Music]
as we go into our prayers of the people
would you guys um pray this out with us
and feel free to
speak out a name or situation that's on
your heart tonight or if you're online
and you'd like to do that in the
comments section
um let's join as a as a community and
stand together and bury each other's
burdens and invite god into the burdens
that we're carrying
[Music]
for the city of saxi texas and for every
city and community and all those who
live in them
we pray to you
for the good earth that you have given
us
and the wisdom and the will to conserve
it
we pray to you
for those who travel on land sea or air
for the old and the sick
for the widow and the orphan
for the injured and the suffering
we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed
the unemployed and the destitute
for prisoners and captives and for all
who remember and care for them
we pray to you
lord we know that you love us
and that you hear us
and so we lift these names and
situations up to you
angelina
[Music]
for the names and the moments that we've
spoken aloud and for those that we've
kept in our hearts we pray to you that
they may have life and light
healing and hope
peace
and a deep sense of your presence
amen
[Music]
come to the water
all who are thirsty
and come to the table
all who are hungry
[Music]
come and feed
and those who are weary
those who are needy
[Music]
[Laughter]
come to the river
[Music]
i am
come to the water
all who are thirsty
come and drink
[Music]
who are hungry
me
[Music]
come to the river
see that he's good
[Music]
oh
is
[Music]
and see that you are good
you're good
to me
and good to this nation good to your
people i will taste
and see that you are good
i will taste and see that you are good
i will taste and see that you are
good you're good to me
i
will taste and see that you are good
i will taste
season you are good
you're good to me
i will taste and see you jesus
[Applause]
i will taste and see your goodness
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my soul
is
[Music]
oh my soul
there's fear
[Applause]
[Music]
so come to the water
and come to the table
all who are hungry
and common
[Music]
hey
jesus we invite you into this moment
with us
we keep our heart open
and ask for you to do your work in us
[Music]
god that above any situation
any surrounding
any
person any law
that you would be the one
who gets our heart
you would be the one
that determines our steps
you would be the one that we would
follow
that you would be our hope
and our light
and our life
god we don't just believe that for the
people that we carry on our hearts but
we also believe it for ourself god
that you would be that life
that light
that peace
that deep presence
that we abide inside of
you are our rock
you are our fortress
you are our deliverer
you are the constant
so we come back home to you god
we anchor our lives in you
have your way in us
and let us be your way in this world
let us love fiercely
let us hope
when everyone else is despairing
let us trust
[Music]
we love you jesus
we're grateful that you love us
be with us tonight and as we go into our
weeks
in jesus name amen
you guys can turn to the people around
you welcome them making them feel at
home and then brett will come and get us
started
well good evening
grace and peace
it is uh it's so good to be with you all
and
um i want to extend that welcome to this
join us online
and i know james is on there as always
and i met um one of our our online
members is named tiffany from houston we
we chatted today we did a little google
meets
and uh
so tiffany if you're you're watching
live or later um what up
you are loved
um
and uh and also anyone here
who is new
i don't see anyone so nope
you all are old-timers
a long time or so
let's get that part um
but i am i'm really just glad to be
together it's it's beautiful and good
and i wanted to um
to start off by reading actually an
email i received this is
from someone
and
they said this i said i woke up today
with an overwhelming happiness a joyful
heart full of god's love
thanks to you
and the table family for transforming me
from
a non-believing sinner to a gay man that
understands god's love and grace someone
who looks forward to reading the bible
daily i no longer feel ashamed to say to
a complete stranger that jesus loves
them or to share my testimony with
anyone at any time i'm trying every day
to be a better evangelist and share the
word of jesus love and grace thank you
again love you
and i just thought it was just a
beautiful expression of
um just what god's up to you know like i
know we gather we're here um so many of
you are like serving and giving and and
just wanting to create a community
that's just reflects christ's love you
know as best we can is it perfect no
but but we're doing our best and um and
good things are happening you know
people are um
meeting christ and being transformed and
that's such a it's just it's so good so
um
so i just want a name i'm just grateful
grateful for that person what god's
doing in their life and and for all of
you
so we are in uh let's see it's part
three
part three of four
in our our series titled hearing god a
listening life
and um our big idea for this series is
is basically that rather than
um
kind of thinking about
hearing god as this i don't know like
the way we've kind of tended to blow it
up in our minds you know as like the big
moment the audible voice the walls are
shaking i'm hearing god you know um that
what i'm truly trying to do in this
series is kind of like calm us down a
little bit and normalize hearing from
god so in other words rather than like
looking for the like two big moments in
my life where it's like
god's spoken i know it you know um
i would i would much rather i mean if
that happens that's great because i'm
not saying like god can't do that i'm
not god can do whatever god wants um
but i i would much rather us live lives
where we are like constantly tuned in
does that make sense like just tune in
to hear god so i'm really trying to kind
of normalize
and um and help us start tuning into how
god speaks like
he's really continually teaching leading
guiding instructing us so um
last week we looked at how that can
happen through scripture
um
and then next week we'll be looking at
how god speaks to us
through community and people
but tonight is
kind of an interesting one it's hearing
god in emotion
emotion um i think this is this is an
interesting one because if you're
anything like me
you might have grown up in like a wing
of the church
where this
was highly suspect you know it's like
feelings
no no no feelings are liars you know and
um
and we've kind of i think been often
taught to kind of distrust your feelings
and i'll get into it um more later i
think you'll see kind of where i'm going
with this because i i understand where
this perspective is coming from what i
want to name is that and what will
unpack is that this perspective is just
lacking some nuance
um
because i think actually god really does
speak in and through um what we feel so
we'll get get more into the details but
our um so our primary text for tonight
is the short one proverbs chapter 20
verse 27 you can
follow along in your bibles or
like 99 of you
on the screen or on your phone
the old it's a yeah it's in the
interesting how times change i mean i
remember when i was a kid like i had to
have my bible i felt naked at church
without my bible you know had like my
little holder and everything else yeah
amazing
um so it says this
uh the human spirit is the lamp of the
lord that sheds light on one's inmost
being
it's kind of it's beautiful poetry isn't
the the human spirit is the lamp of the
lord that sheds light on one's inmost
being
let's let's unpack this because it's a
little bit cryptic like
let's start with that human spirit what
on earth is spirit i think this is one
of those things that can sound a little
bit abstract like i don't know i guess
there's some like
you know invisible part to me or
something i never interact with i'm
never aware of but it's just you know in
me um actually i i think human spirit is
it is referring to that um
kind of connected to the body but also
like not reducible to the body part of
us that kind of more than just
physicality part of us um maybe a good
word would be like our consciousness or
our awareness it's it's interesting how
um we go through our whole lives you
know and we are aware right now
here you are
aware
what a miracle right
i mean no you all don't seem impressed
at all um it really is i mean scientists
cannot figure it out like how what how
how how is it like i heard one guy he'd
explained it he said uh like how so if a
cloud like has trillions of water
particles and there's even some like
electrical charges kind of going between
them but like
a cloud with a trillion water droplets
in the charge like doesn't create cloud
consciousness
oh wait you know i mean there's no cloud
that's like whoa oh i'm an emergent
property of cloud you know like look at
me a cloud mind oh you know like
that doesn't happen
and yet that sense that we i don't know
what i was just doing right then i'm
acting like a cloud that's how clouds
are
um
and yet the the question that befuddle
scientists is well then why is it that a
trillion electrical charges in your
brain suddenly
create this like dr
aware
right you go to sleep like sort of drop
even though you're not completely
unaware but then you're like wait and
here you are and you're like aware of
yourself and to interact with i mean
it's amazing
it's amazing it's a miracle
all of you are a miracle every day here
you are aware like
amazing all right so
i thank you that's that's what i'm
looking for i was gonna do that until
someone said
and then i'm just gonna stop um so okay
so what is it the human spirit so i
think that's a good kind of
understanding of like spirit of
consciousness awareness so the human
spirit is what it's the lamp of the lord
so it's not something disconnected from
god it's like deeply connected to god
your it's your consciousness is a gift
from god
um
but what does it say it goes on to say
that it sheds light on one's inmost
being the hebrew here for inmost being
is literally the belly which is not very
poetic um
you know the the human spirit is the
lamp of the lord that sheds light on
your belly
it's like oh okay um but what it's what
it's talking about is um
in much of the ancient world the the the
core of who you are the the belly the
gut you know this is where you feel
emotion
right it's where you feel things when
you think about it like you get anxious
what happens like that heart starts
you know you get excited
you like feel the you know that we even
have terms for it like butterflies just
got butterflies in my stomach you know
and
um so in other words what i think this
is naming is that your awareness is like
it's a it's a gift from god it's a
complete miracle
and what you can do it's it's like it's
like in modern times you might say god's
flashlight or something you know and you
can actually take that awareness and you
can obviously put it out into the world
as you all are doing now right to me but
you can also go where
inward
right and it sh and what does it do it
sheds light on your
inmost being on all of the feelings and
emotions and like everything that's
going on and we know it's a lot isn't it
there's a lot going on um in our
feelings
and um
so in other words
in that whole process is not something
that's happening again apart from god
that process that ability that capacity
you have to be self-aware and then to
turn that inward to feel things and then
to say oh my gosh god what am i feeling
and why am i feeling that what is it
telling me about my life about the world
about the situation like that whole
process is quite miraculous and
and again not it's not something
happening apart from god that's actually
like as things bubble up and you get i
mean how many of you had that moment
where like you're feeling things
and
all of a sudden you get like
clarity
like that's why it was like i felt this
and i but i couldn't quite discern what
it and all of a sudden
it's that i knew it i knew it was right
in in other words um
this is where we need nuance because i'm
not necessarily saying that you know
every
feeling is a word from the lord you know
what i feel makes it real you know um i
what i'm saying is um
we might a good way to think of it is
that feelings are like a check engine
light
on your spiritual dashboard
right and it's a little bit
well in the check engine light the point
is not the light itself right you're not
like that's the truth no what's the
check engine light is pointing where
like it's directing you under the hood
to the truth to the thing
i think that's a wonderful way to think
about um emotion
is it's like our it's like our check
engine light kind of
especially specifically challenging
emotions because i should name you know
when the when the feelings are positive
then it's quite enjoyable you know i
mean you're feeling good and it's like
oh yes i want to go within god why am i
feeling such joy delight passion you
know like that's not a painful or
difficult process
where it gets hard or when the feelings
are of course we'll call them
challenging emotions not negative uh
because negative of course implies bad
right it's like that is these wicked
emotions you know it's no
they're not they're not bad because
actually so much good
can come from like discerning
you know what we're feeling um and why
we're feeling it um so we'll call them
we'll go with challenging but we we face
those things and it like it brings it
illuminates
um our check engine light
um so what i want to do is is name
um
kind of two ways
that we can kind of two unhealthy ways
that we can process that check engine
light of our emotions kind of two
unhealthy ways we process our
challenging emotions and then one
healthy way where we can start to
discern like what god might be saying
that's not good
so um all right let's start with the
first kind of more a little bit
unhealthy way um a
so we feel the challenging feelings and
then we emotionally lose it
and blame someone or something
for
what we are feeling
um
i had this a little moment i was um
i coached my son dax's soccer team some
of you know this and uh so we were in
like off-season right now but a month
ago we had our last game
and it just so happened
that the way it felt like it kind of
turned into we don't really have
playoffs but it kind of turned into a
little playoff game because we were um
tied for second place and the team we
were playing just happened to be like
the team we were tied with
and so whoever won the game
got second and whoever lost the game got
third
and y'all i mean i usually stay
pretty chill
i mean it's k it's 10 year old soccer so
you know like you shouldn't get too into
it but i must admit um i feel a little
bit i got real
i just got so y'all it was so intense
now it didn't help now i'm making
excuses it didn't help
that um
uh well for one thing it turned out to
be a close game right it wasn't like a
blowout and it's sort of like either
you're just elated like haha yes or you
know dejected like well we've lost this
one no no it was close the whole time
was like they scored we scored they
scored we scored so it was tied
then we get just past half time
maybe um 10 minutes since we would have
like 20 minutes left and our best player
gets kicked out of the game
he deserved it
um
so now we're just like feeling a little
bit of injustice kind of even though we
knew we kind of deserved it but still
you know we're galvanized and then the
other coach he was so intense y'all he
was literally yelling out to his team he
was yelling do you want second place or
third place
do you want second or th i mean y'all
i was like
come on god i mean i'm just like i just
got sucked i got pulled into the moment
it was so intense and then one of my
most trusted defenders i have poured my
life into this young man okay i'm
getting it
um one of my most trusted defenders
literally he gets the ball
he's surrounded by opposing players he
turns he passes back to our goalie he
does it so softly that it becomes a
beautiful pass to the other team i mean
we've taught we've worked on this you
know when you're surrounded like get it
out out to the side soccer players you
know like out to the sides defense out
of there
and he just passes it and the other
team's like
boom they score
and i look at him
and i yell him i call him out by name
that's why i went wrong
i called and i was like
what are you doing
out to the side come on man i like
called and i could see like it's one of
those moments where the notes we
emotionally lose it and blame someone or
something for why we lost it right and
it's like that was me and i'm losing and
all of a sudden it's like it happens and
then i realize i can see the look it was
the look on his face
and i was like oh
bleep
i felt i mean i felt terrible like
he looked i mean he just looked you know
like you just wanted to shrink into you
know like this is y'all this is not how
you coach children's soccer i'm a pastor
i'm a bad person sometimes
so he does come later he came off to
rest and i was like hey man that
i'm so sorry like i you know owned it
but still but still later i was like
processing like what
what was that like what why why did i do
that
why did i because i just got pulled in
like what what happened and i was
thinking like you know honestly the
answer to the why those are such deep
waters what do we feel in our inmost
being
y'all deep deep
waters
um
i was jotting some things down why did i
feel this way well a the intensity of
the other coach and i felt like maybe i
wasn't matching that and that's why we
were failing
you know so i'm bumping up against that
in myself um also
i in that moment we fell behind our best
players on the field
i was deeply afraid of losing losing
hurts
i don't like to hurt
so that's rumbling around um
and then finally as a coach you know you
often feel somewhat powerless and out of
control like you want to get on the
field and do something i can't and so
it's like what can i do
i can yell
and you know i mean like this like
this
this is what was going on in me now i
say none of that as a rationalization
i use it as an example of what not to do
because what happened
i did not
well i did all that later
i didn't shine that awareness the lamp
of the lord
internally in the moment
and because of that i hurt people
and i lost trust
probably not only with that kiddo but
like maybe even to some degree with the
team because then they're afraid like oh
is coach brett gonna do that to you know
to me
um
so this um
so in response to that i mean you could
say like well that's very interesting
life lessons you know
but i think that's this is kind of my
point it's not just a life lesson
i think that that very moment when we
turn
our awareness inward
and we do that work what am i feeling
why am i feeling i think that's actually
a god
moment
and and whatever bubbles up is
often i think the voice of god saying
hello
wake up
what do you see what i'm saying do you
do you recognize what you're feeling and
do you see what that's pointing out not
on the other people
right but in you
that like that's the word of god it
wasn't like god was trying to tell me
that yeah that kid really needs to shape
up you know like no
no god's trying to eliminate something
in me and honestly it's only once i deal
with all of that kind of crap swirling
in me that i can then actually address
him like as a you know player coach
thing without my own issues hijacking
the moment
right
um
all right so that's the first thing we
have to do we we
have the feelings and so we blame
someone something for them um or second
another popular option is we tend to
emotionally shut down
some of you might do this with your
actual check engine light
the light comes on anyone you you don't
have to raise your hand but like that
light comes on you're like well that
can't be that can't be right i don't
trust that that comes on every hundred
thousand miles it's like it's a hundred
and sixty-two thousand well it was
late i don't think it came on for 100
you know
we
light
what light y'all even see a light i
don't even see a check engine light and
it's like the oil light d low oil like
what nope
nope i can ignore this for a long time
maybe even six months i'm not going to
wear that life for six months
um
so what what do we do right it's the
same with feelings feelings
what feelings
you feel any feelings i don't feel any
feelings
nope
those feelings are nothing but pain so
uh i've just decided not to feel them
right
and what are we doing we're just
stuffing those down deep
and just kind of oh those pesky feelings
you know
um
but it's sort of like um going to your
mechanic and be like hey i need you to
turn off that check engine
light i mean they technically can right
like okay
but what are they going to tell you like
no you need to look under the hood bro
right
like you don't just turn off the light
and be like
problem solved
no no the the light's there for
a reason
it's it's directing you right again it's
your it's your feelings emotions they're
your spiritual check engine light
they're god's grace and goodness to you
they alert you
to things happening in you in the world
like they're they're absolutely
essential there's um
uh writer dan allender whose book i have
not read but whose quote
i like very much
he said this um
emotion links our internal and external
worlds
to be aware of what we feel can open us
to questions we would rather ignore
for many of us that is precisely why it
is easier not
to feel
but a failure to feel leaves us barren
and distant
from god
and others
i think that's incredibly insightful
because i i do wonder if some of us here
tonight have felt somewhat barren and
distant
from god and others maybe even for years
and you're like i don't know why
why
what's going see it feels like everyone
else is like feeling thing you know i
just don't feel i don't feel it you know
could it be
that somewhere along the journey
you face some really challenging things
some i mean some big big feelings big
situations really really hard
and
you opted for option b
you know to like you know what we're
just gonna shut all these down
um
but of course the problem is it's like
again turn off that check engine light
but it doesn't solve the underlying pain
the problem it doesn't um
a phrase i like is doing business with
god it doesn't really force us back to
do business with god to like say okay
god what's going on here why am i
feeling these things what's
what's the thing you need to speak to
heal restore transform
mature call me into
what's the invitation for me in it
so that leads us to
third the the more healthy option um we
can opt to feel
to be vulnerable
we can opt to feel to be vulnerable this
of course leads us to one of our core
values here at the table vulnerability
thoughtful inclusive eclectic communal
vulnerable
and um it really wasn't until this
message that i kind of saw that that
connection between i don't know i
thought of
often thought of vulnerability as like
self-disclosure you know being real with
people but i'd never really drawn that
connection with just pure feeling like
so what is vulnerability to to be
vulnerable is to feel
it's to be honest with others about what
we are feeling
and it's to be open to what god may be
saying in and through our feelings
that's vulnerability
coming back to that soccer game moment i
mean what would have been so much better
is for me to have all those feelings
and in the moment say
ouch
ouch brett what are you feeling
anger
fear don't want to lose
afraid of looking dumb compared to this
other coach who's very intense and seems
to be very on top of it insecure
okay feeling a lot of feelings right now
god
what does this say
about me
what are you trying to get at
what's the thing right and i don't mean
this in a shaming way of like i'm
terrible i'm a terrible person god i
know it so tell me how terrible not that
but like god what is this what's this
revealing in me right it's it's a um a
sense of of welcoming
god into the process
you might sum it up like this how will i
know what god is speaking in my inmost
being if i am not aware of what i'm
feeling and why i am feeling it
how will i grow how will i mature
emotionally relationally spiritually
if i am not aware
of what i am feeling
and why i am feeling it
to close i want to give you kind of
three practical steps that's been sort
of the
normal mode in this series um so some of
it i've kind of already hinted at and
named but i wanted to make it real clear
um with our last few minutes so let me
give you kind of three steps to like
okay right that was a lot of words how
do i actually hear god in and through my
emotions and feelings let me try to walk
you through this so step one
be curious and name as specifically as
you can what emotion you are feeling
in other words shine the light of that
awareness
right inward let it illuminate the core
of who you are what all the feelings all
that's going on there and then um
and then do your best to name really as
specifically as you can what you're
feeling in other words you know saying i
feel bad you know is like well it's a
good first step but try to the more
specific you can be the more i think you
can start to tap into the thing god's
inviting you into um my sister-in-law
mindy pointed out this week a great
resource some of you probably already
know it um the feelings wheel
have y'all seen the feelings wheel
it's a good one mindy heard about it
from joe i'm giving her credit don't
worry okay both you credit um
it's a good one so it's i know you can't
read this that's okay i want you just to
kind of have a feel for it so that's
like uh i don't know how many that's
like a hundred emotions
right because this and it's helpful
because you can see they're kind of
color-coded so it's sort of categorized
for are you feeling sad
let's get a little more specific you
know like
you know are you feeling mad
let's get a little more specific you
know often if any uh parents out there
you know this is always a challenge with
the kids like what are you feeling
angry you know it's like well why what's
it you know just it's hard so this can
be a great little tool to like help you
name okay this is
deep breaths i think this is what it is
and
um and so that leads us in to um step
two
welcome the feeling and invite god to
reveal the underlying reality it's
pointing to
a beautiful practice here is something
called welcoming prayer i've done this
for a number of years where you start
feeling all the feelings
and instead of you know option one i'm
feeling all the feelings it's their
thoughts you know or if you know all the
feelings no no no no and instead it's a
practice where you literally just sit
with god name what you're feeling
and
welcome it instead of fighting it
right which is what we're often in a
very oppositional relationship with what
we're feeling i was just like no no no
instead of actually welcoming it
and then inviting god into the midst of
it
so welcome the feeling invite god to to
start to name what's going on under the
hood there of your your
spiritual life
um step three
avoid blaming people or external
situations for your feelings your
feelings are your own
um
this is a hard one that's why i mention
it twice
it's it's hard and it can seem i don't
know maybe it seems a little bit um
cruel you know i of course wrote this
message a few weeks ago so i didn't have
all the events you know going on um but
honestly to
to grow emotionally and spiritually
this might be the most important step
for also the hardest step
so so hard but it transitions you
out of being forever an emotional
victim
because honestly the the world will
continue
to be i'll just go ahead and curse
something there's many kids in here
anyway it's just shitty
it is
and it will probably continue that way
and people
don't be too loud
they're crappy
and they will continue to be that way
and that means you're doomed then
unless you say you know what
i'm not giving you that power anymore
you'd you don't get to dictate to me you
don't get to press the little button and
then i just react you don't get you
don't get to do that anymore
because i'm a child of god
and with his grace and by his spirit i i
can meet god and he can fill me and
inspire and heal me
and so if i'm in this terrible place
that's okay
no shame in that but god do your work in
me heal me transform me show me what
what do i where do i need to
um grow mature heal
what needs to be restored what lies do i
need to stop believing what fears do i
need to stop believing
um
that's a mo it will
it will begin to set you free
so i hope you can tell from this message
um
this is this is for all of us
this is not a message for like the
feelers among us you know the touchy
feely types you know
no no no no no no no actually it's
probably if anything but they tend to be
more in tune and a little bit better at
this
um so really if you're the opposite of
that this message is like triple for you
and your children
well thank me
your spouse well thank me your friends
your partner
will thank me
because we and i say this as someone who
mostly goes for option b
you know shut down um we we need god to
heal and restore us
um
so as we come to the table of the lord
tonight
um may it be a moment maybe like let's
practice
i want it to be a moment where we start
to tune in you know if we're here
we're in the presence of others but
we're also with christ maybe a moment to
tune in what are you feeling tonight
and why
and what's god speaking to you in the
midst of that what's his truth
what's god saying to you
because honestly i can run my mouth all
night
until god says it
we're not really getting anywhere are we
so as you come forward to take the bread
symbolizing
the body of christ the wine symbolizing
his blood it may it be a moment of
communion of connection
of intimacy with god or a moment where
you start to discern and hear god's
voice in the depths of your being
speaking to you through your feelings
so this is the table
not of the church
but of the lord
it's made ready for those who love him
and for those who want to love him more
so come
you who have much faith
and you who have little
you who have been here often
and you who have not been here long
you have tried to follow
and you who have failed
come
come because it's the lord jesus himself
who invites you
and it's his will that those who want to
meet him should meet him here
come to the table
so
[Music]
well gary's coming up and getting
strapped in here um
the song that we're gonna close with
tonight is called be kind to yourself
and jesse sent it to me a few weeks ago
and
i remember his text said i feel like
this would be a really good fit for our
community
and
uh the more i've listened to it the more
i'm like i don't know a community that
this would not be a good fit for
because
the words just as human beings who live
in a crappy planet
[Music]
i just feel like this is a message that
we all need so deeply
and um
as a self-proclaimed enneagram one the
self-critic is strong in this one it is
always speaking to me constantly and i'm
sure some of you guys can relate and um
the man who wrote this song is his name
is andrew peterson he wrote it for his
daughter
and i listened to this little video
where he was introducing
kind of the heart behind it and
it just got me because he was saying
like i watch her spin uh so this is
written from a father's perspective as
he's watching his child spend these
vicious cycles of like being upset and
then being upset at herself for being
upset
and then you're upset that you're upset
then you're upset at yourself for you
know what i mean and it's just and i was
just like that is so myself i beat
myself up more than i would ever beat
anyone else up you know
and sometimes we just need someone to
say like
be kind to yourself
for those of you who know adam he's
great at sending emails all the time
that says mindy be kind to yourself
[Music]
so if you need someone in your life to
remind you of that adam's a great person
to become friends with um
but i also feel like that's that's god's
message to us be kind to yourself i like
the thing i created you know and even
when you get it wrong
there's a lot of there's a lot of mess
there but there's also this beautiful
creation that i'm doing a good work in
so
be kind
so anyway i'll let gary take the rest
you've got all that
[Music]
you'd rather be anyone else
i love you just the way that you are
i love the way he makes you
be precious to yourself
be kind to yourself
[Music]
i love you just the way that you are
i love the way you shape in your heart
be kind to yourself
[Music]
learn to love your enemies
you can't expect to be perfect it's a
fight you gotta forfeit you belong to me
whatever you do
so lay down your weapon don't take a
deep breath and believe that i love you
i love you just the way
[Music]
kind yourself
learn to love your enemies
[Music]
oh man guys
i feel like it's so hard to walk out of
here tonight i kind of want to push the
chairs aside and sit in a big circle and
just get to hear everyone's hearts
beautiful sermon beautiful worship
um and in the name of vulnerability my
autopilot is just to make jokes whenever
i'm when i'm hurting i'm really sad in
the last couple of weeks have in my
little world have been a roller coaster
of not bad things necessarily
but just
exhausting to the core things um and
then i have several friends sitting in
here who i know are juggling and holding
some really really hard things and my
heart feels that my heart feels the
shootings and my heart fills these laws
and it's
oh
[Music]
it's hard
and i'm so thankful for this community
for you people who are real and raw and
safe to say
that
you know
my skirt has pockets and i'm really sad
um
yeah
[Music]
if you feel comfortable i want to invite
us all to stand
and if you feel comfortable holding the
hand or putting a hand on the person of
the shoulder next to you take a step
near that person let's grab hands and i
want to
speak this benediction
over you guys um
and as i'm saying it over you will you
think of the person next to you and lift
them up as well
you are a child of god
this is true on your best today and is
true on your worst day
so as you go into your week ahead with
its undetermined highs and lows and
everything in between go
filled with the assurance that you are
loved you are worthy and you are
accepted just as you are
and go filled with god's holy spirit and
the dire desire to extend these same
gifts of grace and unconditional love to
everyone in contact with
amen peace be with you i'll be in the
back if anyone wants to share a hug or
pray
um i would love to do that with you
[Music]
oh
me
[Music]